des allures de ville fantômes seuls des
véhicules militaires s'aventurent encore
dans les rues de bark mouth et parfois
quelques habitants en état de choc
effrayé par les bombardements
ma soeur est sous ses décombres et
personne ne peut venir la récupérer tout
le monde a peur à cause des obus
avant la guerre la ville comptait 70 000
habitants mais aujourd'hui nombreux sont
ceux qui ont préféré partir car la
région de Barth mouth est devenue ces
derniers jours la nouvelle ligne de
front
les principaux points chauds du Dombasle
sont soledar et barmut ou des combats
extrêmement violents se poursuivent les
occupants ont mobilisé toutes leurs
forces contre les nôtres dont 2000
prisonniers qui se trouvent parmi les
mercenaires
des forces russes qui avancent au Sud et
à l'Est ici contrairement au reste du
pays elle regagne du terrain
dans cette région les soldats russes
sont un avantage la proximité de leur
base arrière avec la ville de Donetsk à
seulement une centaine de kilomètres